don't bring anyone love into this so the
next picture and this is a water what I
brought it's called civil body from
Norway and this picked the the bottle
already is kind of stunning because I
will open this bottle is it this one oh
is one and it's in the key this is like
what you buy high-end liquor comes in a
case like that it has the price of a
high-end liquor it does so it runs
hundred and fifty dollars in the
restaurant here daddy
yes 50 bucks that cost you when you want
to buy it retail and hundred and fifty
were charging at the restaurant but we
are selling it people are really
addicted to it really really interesting
it so is this a flat water yes I brought
still waters today I thought like today
is still November month we drink a still
water still water this is from Norway
from Norway this comes from from the
under actress so it's a polar iceberg
water so the middle content obviously is
extremely low 21
TDs mm-hmm very very low because this
water has never been touched on the
ground it's like rain water drips down
it goes right away on the ice glacier
and freezes up this water is around
15,000 years old what's in the bottle
right here and I see the picture right
here so they're harvesting these
icebergs and all some people would say
like are you not smart and so you you we
all know like global warming and
everything yeah oh you're like taking
the icebergs even my way yeah no these
are icebergs whoo breaking down like
totally normal
they're starting to dilute then into the
North Sea and when they are deluded you
cannot use that water anymore then it's
like heavily salted yeah so they're
picking up this huge icebergs and you
can see like they are tons they're super
heavy they have our own vessel they're
picking up these icebergs and then
melting them down into this bottle so
that's something very cost intensive and
they're cost intensive and also it's not
gonna be that they're not gonna make
million now and I think they did 10,000
bottles faster so that's why the price
point is gonna be elevated it's
something very very unique that's a
fascinating so it's a very fun
interesting water to start your soup and
remember maybe oh my goodness and it's
gonna be as you mentioned a pretty low
yeah yeah but but it's still a distinct
flavor or no that's interesting putz so
I had three bottles already in tasting
in all three bottles tasted slightly
different and that makes sense because
it's a mother it's a product of nature
again and all these icebergs they're
floating into the sea so obviously all
these icebergs have a slightly different
flavor to it and the name again is small
bodies bodies are Reacher and Norway and
they calling that water swells of our
body so let's see what this version
tastes like mm-hmm to me it's very
smooth yeah yeah very very smooth I
think so too it's very smooth but it has
when you drink it and it's it's right
away gone yes like it's almost dries out
your palate I think yeah it doesn't
really have this refreshing aspect to it
that's interesting and that is because
it's lacking minerals because it's
lacking yes because there's not enough
minerals in there so the your body on
your mouth saying like hey what's not
gonna get some more can I get some more
because there's like barely anything in
there so I want more water to get more
minerals interesting that's a good water
I like it it's extremely because it's so
smooth it's very nice for wines so when
you have like a tenon rich red wine or
something like that yeah or maybe a
risky what you just told me that will
very very cool work with us because this
this heaviness of alcohol will be smooth
the way of this very smooth water so
it's a it's a very good water and I
don't want to drink everything because I
think your wife Christina need to drink
something as well and she will kill both
of us I think when we probably when we
killing the bottles here just for us and
we don't we don't share that some be
mean but I have to say that is a very
pleasurable tasting in other words well
it's enjoyable I think so too
it's not it's something that you go like
oh okay I mean the satisfying sip of
water oh absolutely
it wouldn't satisfy my pocket I have to
say because it's pretty expensive so for
150 in a restaurant but so nobody could
go out and buy it
where would you buy stuff like that oh
so you can buy because a lot of people
ask me as well I came out and where can
you buy all this crazy war just what you
had last time on the show and we said
it's a crime is turn Florida so these
are the people who can actually
are they important mostly of the very
unique voters in this country so you can
call a Brett is his name I call my Astro
and can you say that
slower aqua my astro oh okay yeah okay
so and you like aqua maestro yes here we
go okay look my German accent my fellow
I know and again believe me I just
wanted to bait you I wanted to make sure
thank you
so aqua maestro Akiva maestro in Florida
and you will find them right away last
time and I will talk to Brett again last
time they gave actually 10% of for
everybody who mentioned your mom sounds
podcast what yes so because they had so
many inquiries suddenly for his guild
okay
so that was kind of cool and I think
this is a nice thing and for sure but
we'll do this again when you call him up
and say hey I listen to your mom sells
podcast and I heard marketing yeah for
sure he will do something again okay
he's a nice guy
yeah that was likes to hide very
interesting guys switch to the next one
here the next next picture Regan you can
see the hassles fucking nuts where
there's ice books are collecting so this
ship goes out picks up like scoops up
almost like a fisherman yes he picked
shrimp and just has a boat full of
icebergs yeah and then they take that
back to some factory and correct correct
and then they are deluding at this water
obviously into the bottle that's so it
really has never touched anything nope
trust ice books and the glass that's
wild man
and then our mouth now yeah that's that
is why it's a fun product yeah like this
and they won because I told you I was
just Russell Easley in swaps of our bars
well body valve as well by the iceberg
water and they just want the in China
was a big water competition and they was
like the silver medal for taste and then
they won the gold medal for the the
product in general the presentation the
presentation is awesome yeah that's
outstanding
yeah I think so too and that's I have to
say that's like a lot of people at my
restaurant they're obviously going in
the water mania and they see this
beautiful bottle and they say like do
not watch page I want to drop 150 bucks
for water yeah why not why not
experience some people driving a
Lamborghini
yeah tool to the gym or to hot yoga and
some people
how we rolling now yeah Stace so what's
what's this next one so the next one I
was very surprised when I heard about
this there Chuck Norris has a water come
on this is the official Chuck Norris
water
cforce from Texas from his privately
owned ranch really yes he has a water
and as he was by yes I reached out to
them and they were so happy to give me
some products and said like hey that's
so cool what you're doing so I did
already a video on YouTube about the
taste profile of cforce and I thought it
would be a fun thing to bring it here to
the show not today
because I'm a big Chuck Norris fan I
have to admit this I think he's he's
cool and crazy and so I went to the
homepage as well and they're saying so
Chuck Norris heard that you guys are
thirsty and so he punched the grounds
and made the earth cry yes therefore we
get some water now so it's Mother's
earth tears hey man I mean I'm willing
to give him a shot Chuck Norris can try
anything knows but isn't a tease deal
spring water and I love this and they're
very proud about this they are saying no
we are not purify anything we want
minerals TDS is run 300 on this water so
okay that's so that's a pretty pretty
good stable that's some mineral yeah yes
by US law this is actually mineral water
considered everything right 250 TDS
means it's a mineral water okay so this
is considered to be a mineral spring
water from Texas cforce mm-hmm let's see
let's give it a shot
Cheers it definitely tastes different oh
yeah from the from the small body yeah I
think so too I'd has a little sweetness
to it I think hmm
I'm not I don't know I'm not that into
it you're not into a Chuck Norris ow I
mean I'm in Detroit I don't know what it
is about it it's like it's almost like
it's just under the taste I'm supposed
to be tasting or just over something
that's supposed to be masking I don't
know it's like it's like it's very so
you feel maybe because the name Chuck
Norris on it you feel something powerful
maybe a Vichy or Roy or something like
this that's something like outrageous
and taste I thought I just had different
expectations maybe that's it and that's
might be what it is as well called the
tedious the 300 again I think it's a
good product obviously it's not so
unique then maybe this far body's story
or the skill of what we had last time we
change shapes into milik when you're
shaking the bottle it doesn't have
something so extremely unique obviously
also you know what it is also is that I
think I mean without being as familiar
with waters as you are when you said 300
and that this would be considered
mineral water I think my brain was also
like oh no it's gonna have a taste to it
and then he's like very subdued okay so
that makes sense yeah I didn't taste I
don't really taste much with it yeah yep
but it was for me interesting to see
that Chuck Norris has that's very
important yeah and I wanted to test that
out and it was like an interesting
imagine trying to get into the water
game like trying to get into bottled
water seems like maybe we should create
a you mom's house yeah I mean like yeah
that market before real all the mummies
for all the people who wearing their
jeans what would be our game plan I mean
what source are we gonna tap oh I have a
lot of connection there yeah that is
actually easy for me okay
the marketing though right because I
have a brand of spots called Beverly
Hills 9800 that's right so and it was
last week on the Jimmy Fallon show
that's very okay Jimmy Fallon taste and
you can see it on YouTube right now 2
Chainz taste it with Jimmy Fallon 9 h2o
on the show and and it was a blind taste
test
No
tap the famous New York tap was
considered to be one of the best tap
waters in the States versus 9 th - oh
and it's a very funny video it is oh my
god
so Jimmy Fallon is like looking at this
two glasses and tasting the first class
and realized holy shit that is so bad
yeah this has to be tapped and it was
New York tap and he's like and he feel
almost like embarrassed and he said like
I love the city I am being grown up here
in New York but this is outrageous
like that water's just no way I'm gonna
drink this really to change it right
away I don't I don't drink tap that's
not my style that's not how I roll yeah
I don't drink tap and then they tasted 9
h2o and Jimmy Fallon into the camera
like oh la la this is expensive shit all
right that was good it was a funny very
funny
your water's available everywhere yeah
not really everywhere right now because
it's a very small production water as
well and Beverly's I know it was
actually sold out right now right after
the Jimmy Fallon show obviously we sold
hot right away you have be thrilled it's
crazy it was great but we need to
produce no again so it's very tricky and
it's not that easy a lot of people
always think already they just open it
tap and they're filling this this no no
because I'm a maniac I'm German I want
to be like crazy and I want to be a
control freak when it comes to us I want
to make sure this water is perfect yeah
so we're sourcing that water from the
San Diego Mountains and I'm very kind
I'm very strict about where the sauce is
coming from which plastic which bTW were
using because I don't want to have any
bpa any chemicals in there
it's a beautiful blue bottle the bottle
what we showcase on the Jimmy Fallon
show is a glass bottle as well I'm very
strict about the glass as well I'm like
a control freak when it comes to this
for me quality is the non plus ultra and
I don't want to just give some water on
the mass-market and should you just make
a fast buck That's not me
yeah they are for right now 98 shows
sold out but it will definitely come
back when better than when I feel the
quality is perfect and then I will
release the next batch great that's
awesome I want to get a batch of that
that was important I'll bring it next
time I will bring it next time you have
one more one more
we go into Australia
my life in this bottle and you can see
it already on the label it's a little
bit nap well they sent me a whole case
of water and actually just three bottles
survived the rest was broken Wow so
that's all the time I have this and
obviously my landlord at my apartment oh
I see like what the hell is this always
why are you getting all the speed up
packages yeah from all around the world
on these days and this is the fun cool
thing about me as a water sommelier that
literally people from around the world
sending me water snow all the time yeah
I love that it's really fascinating it's
also your passion oh yeah it's
completely fastening to taste all the
different mineral waters from around the
world so aqua life has a TDS of 1300 so
this is considered a very high mineral
water this is still version and this is
from a fastening because mostly high
mineral waters are sparkling waters but
this is are they water sparkling is
because it's more palatable for minerals
no I don't want to say this but a lot of
high mineral content waters coming with
co2 out of the grounds okay so they're
already co2 and aqua life is still water
from and rainy you've tried this yes
yeah I tried this already a thousand
thousand three hundred this is
definitely gonna have a flavor yeah it
has to it has a texture has a texture it
has a texture okay oh yeah this is heavy
water yeah this is for me lutely heavy
saying I never X and this for me
fastener this is like what I love when
I'm tasting waters this is so unique and
textures almost if you drink like high
percentage milk or olive oil this is
like the the mouthfeel you know it's
funny
your Broca's everyone's brain sends
different thoughts I'm anticipating like
my my moment before was like I was gonna
be salty like that was my my thoughts
it's like oil mmm like smooth like egg
mineral oil like
it's almost like if olive oil was
something you could drink right yeah
it's like a richness to it when you
would close your eyes you would think
you would drink olive oil or you would
drink milk or something yes you would
not think this is water because it's so
heavy in your palette and this is from a
fascinating that's the reason I'm trying
to get them they don't have distribution
right now in the States
I'm trying to get them on my new water
mania whatever lounge at patina next
month because I think it's something so
unique I want to showcase that there's a
water for me again like what my brain is
like holy cow they're so cool that
mother nature gives me something so
crazy and so another three for me by far
the most unique taste oh yeah definitely
and the first ones by far the most
unique story yeah and and also very
satisfying yes yeah yeah and I think
it's an interesting exercise again to
see three still waters this time last
time I brought yes it was amazing and I
wanted to want it to showcase even still
water taste differently and has a
different texture and and can taste
completely different this is so cool
yeah man I'm fascinated and so again if
you want to try people because we got
hit up like you know the people wanted
me to keep posting about the waters and
aqua maestro
yes in mm-hmm bookmarked that you should
if you are a foodie if you love
restaurants you come in Los Angeles go
to patina and you could even possibly
meet Martin and and try something trying
to be there on a daily basis trying last
and then put a reminder in your phone to
get Beverly Hills a dates to 900 h2o
when it comes back on the market
[Music]